so obviously a lot of emotion for
everyone
tonight's coming into a steam how are
you guys able to stay focused man you
know just one in the win the game when
I'm going to finish up the road trip
great you know just knowing no no
personally I know either wanted me to
come out here and try the ball and you
know it still just be great so I mean
everybody said you know what I mean is
you know words can explain his impact he
had on this floor you know the emotional
impact he had on everybody you know what
I mean
you know we're a team from LA so we know
Elvis history with him it seemed like
both teams tonight both the Clippers and
the magics came out a little out of
sorts probably because of the news today
who was the key in getting you guys to
recover
scheming and the road trip on a positive
I mean you know before the game we both
we ran out the clock 24 seconds you know
for Kobe and then they got a half court
violation eighty seconds to do a tribute
tourism so you know just things like
that which is you know keep the game out
of whack and I mean like I said just you
know you end up jennie-o generally
running and you just got to play
basketball us our job you know decide
he's gonna be missing I think it was
hard for all of us to do our jobs today
no thank you collective Jamie thanks
great stuff Kauai in typical Mambo